I saw signs all over India that said to
let t-o-l-e-t and I was like there's
just random signs about like are they
releasing apartments and I was like oh
toilet yeah
it's just signs like hey you need a
because I'll sell you one got it
nice all over everywhere but that's we
need toilets still to that point but I'm
am I wrong
no it's not hold on hold on this is
about to be historic it's everywhere
because that means for sale
I don't even know who the you
contact it means like oh yeah this is
for sale I saw it on Windows I'd be like
oh yeah that must be a place that's
available no you see that you see that
everywhere like on buildings on
like signs everywhere yo get shoved oh
it's the least damn it